what up guys this is Tony trim thanks
for tuning in to another episode of the
handsome rambler episode number 50 with
our good friends al Jackson and Kevin
Bozeman we recorded this one a little
while back while we were touring through
the Midwest and it's a very special
episode it's number 50 we did it we
knocked out 50 anyways Hannibal's got
some shows coming up I'll be joining him
first one will be in st. Charles
Illinois on March 18th at the Arcada
theater March 26 in Little Rock Arkansas
at revolution music room March 27th in
Memphis Tennessee at mingle wood hall
and then we got five shows in Nashville
at Zanies that's from March 29 through
March 31st then April 15 will be at will
be in Portland Oregon at the Keller
auditorium May 10th will be in Boise
Idaho at the Knitting Factory concert
house May 11th at Spokane what is it
Spokane or spa county whatever Spokane
Washington at the Knitting Factory there
and then May 17th in Port Chester New
York at the Capitol Theatre May 18th in
Brooklyn at Brooklyn Academy of Music's
Opera House and May 19th in Philly at
the Merriam Theatre so you can get
tickets at Hannibal Buress com backslash
calendar will just go to Hannibal Burres
calm I'm sure you could figure that out
how to get tickets I'll see you guys
there enjoy the show
[Music]
start the soul started
[Music]
so welcome to another episode of
handsome Rambla I'm your host
Hannibal burials and I'm your co-host
Tony Trey yeah yeah to guests and
Friends of our show
Kevin Bozeman took my direct left yes al
Jackson to the level Kevin bull what's
up yo yo man day drinking is the best
it's the best because when you get older
the nightlife eventually pushes you out
because you like too old to be in
certain spots but they drinking that's
when the grown folks is out like from 4
to 7 day drinking you you is where you
build character yeah I'm with Bill
character character I'm sorry sir
because doing you day drink you gotta
know stuff about yourself you got to
know things about who you are because
you will be isolated sometimes you want
to have hours where you just by yourself
and you got to be cool with that that's
a character builder most people who
don't have character always have to be
around people because they have no
character they have no life no
personality so they always have to be
around people which is why they going
out clubbing all the time and it's
really loud but day-drinking
it's just you in a bar with last night's
episode of SportsCenter running and
there's just nobody talking to you and
you just drinking and you cool with that
because you have character
[Music]
this podcast has evolved since I've last
done things a little bit different like
when you had a girlfriend that she moved
to Portland
changing the pottery yes put what back
you say it for the better
oh please I put it back
we hire one at Ohio Iowa right nuts a
half so cool
Corner oh poor cornucopia open you it's
Sunday afternoon up in the Midwest I got
a t-shirt on my chest I used to watch a
lot of wrestling
daddy brown with the [ __ ]
what all right enough
oh okay I was about to get my saw saw
you pick that [ __ ] up a little bit here
you want yeah
that's that be that's that be boy beat
you can rap basic if you're a basic is
[ __ ] ahead you get like an 80 slow I
went over to the street you know what it
is 34 and drunk
I ain't got no kids and none of that no
kids I know what [ __ ] cuz if I had some
kids that [ __ ] kids all the kids I got
is off my laptop keys yeah yeah there's
not shout outs to mulk for all this
great business chop them up in like HP
you said some you talking about and Bose
I know you feel about this HP just meant
to wrestling and I remember being a
little kid and growing up and watching
wrestling's I was like the first time I
didn't have a word for racism but I
would be watching and I'd be like this
isn't right but I didn't have the words
for it like with like Kamala the Ugandan
giant yeah but like you don't you know
it's racist for like you're too young to
like put that thought there they were
just like it feels like when you see
like that makes that doesn't make me
feel good it was a lot of data WWE made
a lot of strong choices with the
characters are you talking about the
junkyard dog with the dog collar around
his neck
dog or we could be talking about Virgil
who was a slave to ted dibiase oh we
could be talking about Yokozuna was just
a big sumo wrestler well we could talk
about the Iron Sheik Jesus Christ who
talked about his rival sergeant
slaughter he made a crossover in the GI
Joe or mom he did and he Spartan GI Joe
I think he was originally GI Joe and
then they took that character well what
about the the to Australian twins that
was who would a boy boy and they'd be
just running around throwing their arms
up bushwhackers which bikers yeah I do
there's a lot of so yeah they were
hillbillies right
probably the bogans the bogans holy [ __ ]
yet which we found out what what city we
were in when we found out that bogans is
like a slur that's Australia oh I was in
our [ __ ] man I was in Australia Nate I
was talking to our driver and she was
like yeah there's a lot of bogans out
there I would [ __ ] it's a bug and she's
like it's a Australian hillbilly and
then yeah and then the woman's recall I
shirley's or something right
is that a demeaning time yeah there it
was bogans and surely tzer's so I it
wasn't surely but it was something like
that that's like we should start doing
it we should adopt foreign like slang
foreign racist hurtful [ __ ] and bring it
here get out of here you surely know
goddamn bogan I feel like that would
make you matter is my ecology that cuz
you know it was bad you know it doesn't
matter what you say it's it's how you
say it really mostly oh you know one of
my guys he he said in high school he's
the racist people would call black
people Reagan's
cuz Reagan backward is Megan so they'd
call him Reagan's [ __ ] I know but
that doesn't smell [ __ ] backwards
weird pronunciation of it you have a
good imagination if you can expand don't
you just call him Riggins
why don't you just call him Ron and
Nancy's because John Reagan's from is
known here to be he's the only right
running back in a Hall of Fame if I'm
correct
so besides Bronco Nagurski so he's the
only current in a recent time so you
can't call someone and I can't and mean
it to be hurtful what are you talking
about rigors from Friday Night Lights
talking about John Riggins from the
Washington Redskins if you a white races
dude you're not gonna call a black due
to rigging cuz John Riggins represents
everything that you stand for and I'm
not saying that Riggins is a racist do
but Riggins it's like the Reagan is in
Ronald Reagan No
but I'll said why don't you just call
them Riggins Wow and I was saying that's
why you can't call them Riggins because
John Riggins is the [ __ ] dude if you
were white dude they grew up you like 60
years old John Riggins is your [ __ ]
hero is his mic all starting all of it
now he should be shitty bald he's not a
hall-of-famer bald for like seven eight
years two years him and what we're done
they did it you can't yo man I like that
we shot out to Tampa I like the way you
cleared out that path to be so wor dunk
and get that 4.1 yard for carries so al
man you you've been in Denver this year
yeah bro I moved to Denver from LA I got
a job hosting the TV show there and brah
I think Scott it's called daily blast
laughs look at that thank you for
letting me plug that you can watch every
day
we're in 39 markets and on YouTube every
day but like honestly man I didn't
realize and I was telling you this
yesterday in the truck I didn't realize
how much I needed that man I'd been in
New York LA in Miami the last 20 years
and brah sometimes like you just need to
chill out I just get up in the morning I
make coffee I look at the mountains
before my day starts every day what time
what time does the show the UH we air we
go live from 12:00 to 3:00 every day
yeah TV show this three hours long it's
we we do the same hour over and it's not
over and over again but we at the reset
four separate several markets different
time zones so every show is like a new
show for a new time zone week so we're
you know some cities were on for an hour
some cities were on for half an hour
right now we're starting at 39 Marcus
show was doing real [ __ ] good thank
y'all for anybody listening it's
important please keep that up but yeah
man I didn't know Hannibal I needed a
schedule doc yeah I've been like like
you know like you pull like a like a
wild cat into a house that's just been
outside for like ten years and he's like
wait a second mom my meals a regular now
there's a cat box is still there and
they're not chasing me I'm like oh [ __ ]
I got a schedule I'm a square I get a
paycheck
cut from a payroll is in there every
Thursday I'm like man I like I have a
job now and I'm not mad at it done
structure genuinely seemed happy dude
I'm happy I lost a bunch of weight
matters like of my boyfriend assumption
that you're smart and you're smoking
legal marijuana Moken legal in its in
its recreational which is even different
than la where at least you know every
year I have to go take a fake you know
doctor visit or something like it you
just walk in there by and I'll say
August or my marrow the guy that that
that's at my that's at my marijuana
store is the most knowledgeable human
being on any subject he's like it's like
he knows more about weed that anybody
knows about anything you could walk in
there and be like dude I'm having
headaches and you know when I try and
read I get he's like though here's why
you brought this dude knows everything
so he can tell you not only what to do
and but why you should do it yeah and
you just tell Mike what you want to do
you can walk in and be like hey man I'm
Hannibal man I'm dude I'm trying to
learn how to play guitar on YouTube and
I want to be a little high but I still
want to be focused on the keys Oh
take this it should do its we're we're
at the point with drugs were like people
turn street drugs into medicinal drugs
that help you do [ __ ] yeah yes that
happens with legalization because with
the percentages of CBD versus THC it
that makes a big difference strains I
don't give a [ __ ] like when they say
indica sativa I don't give a [ __ ] but
when they show you the percentages of
THC versus CBD that makes a big
difference which is why the states need
to red light district red light dish
come on y'all keep it fit this red-light
district people get money people be
funny when they got that money they drop
it no hos they drop it on clothes
y'all frozen like dis tree Hannibal yeah
thoughts on a red-light district could
it worked if every major city had a
red-light district absolutely think
weight would think though Tony I mean it
was awesome loosen this down there it
wouldn't just be awesome is it like it's
not no wait
whenever something happens in this when
it's first brought out it's going to be
a surge but then it's going to mellow
out the first year or two is gonna be
off the charts craziness but then it's
gonna mellow out and just be a part of
the community remember drinking used to
be 18 and over and then it turn to 21
and over but it mellowed out [ __ ] but
answer Amsterdam got rid of their
red-light district though did ya do
Amsterdam is like [ __ ] you might as
well go to goddamn Vermont yes you
noticed like no one goes to Amsterdam
anymore you never remember like every
like 10 years girl what the hell I've
been there ain't nobody been an answer
do it unless you just want to go see the
countryside and have some Heineken Wow
yeah that's gone so what would be your
your anti red-light district what give
me a reason why
I would think I'm thinking property
value and crime because it's gonna be
even though it's legal there's gonna be
some illegal sex trafficking and as soon
as they bust some ring with someone
underage girls they're like it's gonna
be too much right yes it would
definitely be a interesting transitional
phase you I think as I pathetical it
would be successful in like a city where
the Vipers already loose like New
Orleans or chamois of Vegas yeah well
it's already legal on Vegas isn't it
yeah we like that weed is legal but it's
not like I thought prostitution was
this is psyche tolerate I don't know the
exact laws are you saying that the first
red-light district wouldn't it's not
gonna break out New Hampshire I'm gonna
go on record I'm just saying I just
think that there would be too much there
be like we we are we come from a
puritanical society and that's why like
we don't have our sex shops are always
weird you know I'm saying it got weird
windows or you can't see in the back
it's just like we are really weird about
drugs we're really weird about sexuality
but not with alcohol so our society is
like super you know we we suppress our
sexuality and we increase our alcohol
ISM with which then like that's why like
you look at [ __ ] like Anthony
Weiner and [ __ ] like people that have
sex issues but it's so pushed down if
you come out be like a man I'm into this
I'm into that that's just bad but I
guarantee you we should look this up
right now Tony look at like the number
one porn downloaded in the state we are
in Iowa and like it's freaky [ __ ] right
because [ __ ] want to see that
[ __ ] yeah man but they kitty I feel
people feel like they can't express
themselves Bozeman is over here
furiously checking fantasy football is
in both a porn conversation and I want
to know it my fantasy is Sunday it is
Sunday afternoon we drop in this in the
United States what do you guys think is
the the number one genre of porn like
look at do you think it's just jokes do
goats animals [ __ ] chicks right asian
asian lesbian wrestling
[Laughter]
we all have our own path to love
Hannibal yeah that's my thing I like to
watch chicks wrestle sorry I do like the
hoodoos of videos like the combat was
with a wrestle and then whoever loses
gets [ __ ] with a dildo Hannibal do you
think I haven't been a member of that
site for the last five years wait you
have four memberships yeah yeah I just
have this one yeah yeah it's like look
man everybody's like how do you why do
you pay for one it's free site yeah
there's porn that everybody can see this
free within the chefs you pay for it's
like the [ __ ] you need to say nothing
nothing that's the best when it's free
you got to know if something's free and
there there's something out there that's
worth paying for I think that's a gym
yeah I should pay for some some of it
just to support the Arts you know yeah
you ever bought a a porn star something
off of her Amazon wishlist no but I told
you I used to I used to live next door
to a drew Fox yeah literally for years I
lived next to a true Fox the porn star
and in front of her door
there would be gifts every day and not
in a podcast I'm trying to over everyday
flat-screens be I'm talking about like
gifs watches clothes fan base ooh she
has a family babe rewind to what you
said ah porn stars wish list on Amazon
explain to me what the yeah wish list is
say you could have a wish list where you
just say I want people to buy me these
things it's like a registry before
individual basically for do the jackal
so you do like so I've seen it where
they'll have it in their Twitter bio
they say this is my wish list and you
click on it and it's just a bunch of
[ __ ] that they want more focus to buy
for them what that's yeah dude that's
crazy it is it though if you can link it
you could just link it to any social can
you delink it to like instance a link
and then you just and then they click it
and then people just buy your [ __ ] your
if they want to your not porn star and
what's gonna be on your wish
let's go for me yeah any of you who
still was gonna be number one I was just
get some [ __ ] I would never buy I wanted
some leather pants can a [ __ ] get some
leather pants I was a porn star we're
about just me on my wish now that I know
you're a porn star males porn star yeah
you're a male in this area Tony okay
what is your wish list does it does it
have to concern porn cuz why can't I
just be a porn stars you can answer
everyone I'm only giving you what you
are you a porn star
okay Tony [ __ ] would just be music [ __ ]
yeah a couple of key beats by dre you
don't want no no no Padre just a
[ __ ] look at elephant at the end
of it okay so I'm about to go to this
this porn stars her wish list okay but
she has a woman spaghetti-strap bodycon
party bad his dress a Conair extreme
handheld fabric steamer she just added
these are new items she added him
October 20th which means somebody buying
other stuff she had a another bodycon
Club where like a tight dress what else
you got Amazon is that a whoo
Amazon echo some boots yeah some wigs
some cosplay wigs a bunch of wigs a big
top babe costume she's just basically
tightening up her life basically I don't
even I don't want that much stuff in
general yeah I don't I don't want to
start a witness that's interested in a
also I don't know I see you have knives
set up buy her some knives buy her some
lives should I buy her some knives
yeah she wants to get her cooking skills
at weight as you watching too much of
James Brown dr. B
shabbat smashing some nine forever21
gift card for 50 bucks
a Starbucks hundred dollar gift card
this one been up here since July I'm
gonna get these now she's got some
luggage on here 240 good taste some
Cuisinart knives
i'ma buy these knives actually know her
we've never we've better cover sighs she
said uh she was sitting next to me when
I went to the avian porn Awards how does
that by the way it was it was it was
surreal cuz it was just just seeing
people accept the wars for for it and
they just give speeches with sincerity
about an anal scene which is that that's
their work but it's just it's just
jarring isn't it refreshing to see
somebody that's not scared of what they
do and not being weird that all right I
mean me and this guy we work really hard
on the scene and we're really proud of
it I think that's some dope-ass [ __ ] but
you said something earlier man is kind
of interesting to me and I want to get
y'all opinion too
do y'all think we're like the first
generation that doesn't want a lot of
[ __ ] because I remember like my my my
dad not so much for like my grandparents
you know you go in the basement there's
a ton of [ __ ] attic there's a ton of
[ __ ] there'd be like a guest bedroom
this packed with [ __ ] and everybody's
grandparents our quarters [ __ ] yeah
because they all grew up in like every
you know they grew up hold on a Great
Depression and like mother [ __ ] like
don't throw that aluminum foil away we
rinse that off and use it you know cuz
mother [ __ ] you might not have that
[ __ ] again but I feel like I throw so
much [ __ ] away that I don't use like my
apartment look like a spy lives there
right you know anyway you don't need
photo albums anymore cuz you got phone
you got a phone and could get all your
photos you don't need a photo of me
anymore so [ __ ] like that and then once
you start getting rid of that it's all
just getting rid of keepsakes and [ __ ] I
got my son's first pair of Jordans lit
up on them of course yeah you keep you
don't throw away baby [ __ ] yeah
keep those joists III disagree with you
guys I like to keep a lot of stuff just
because I like to when I buy things I
like to buy them of high quality I was
gonna that Tony I was just about to say
you buy you'd never buy if you get
headphones you get four hundred our
headphones never I don't like to buy
things that are disposable is what I'm
saying so I hold onto a lot of [ __ ] but
that doesn't mean that I buy a lot of
[ __ ] I just buy that one thing in high
quality and hold on to it as for as long
as I can at least yeah I lose it yeah
you're like you'd like to kind of do
that you don't seem like you lose a lot
of things though sunglasses man don't
belong to us sunglasses belongs to the
streets Oh
sunglasses belong to the streets they're
all with us temporarily hi every time
we've gone out to eat this dish road
trip
I've always grab somebody sunglasses
because they left them on the table it's
almost like you're trying to lose them
set them down and then it's always like
oh thanks man dammit sunglasses are a
weird item in that you have them on your
body but anytime you go indoors if
you're wearing them you look like an
[ __ ] like I do now what's the most
you've ever dropped the sunglasses like
you knew you did take a [ __ ] with those
sunglasses all remove your shirt that's
character we're talking about how this
Kerry Hannibal stifling my creativity by
not letting me do the podcast with my
shirt off
what's up with that yeah what's up with
that I'll just be contrary I'm not
talking about Sir Thomas ah you guys go
to shirt off so I was just saying
opposite I appreciate you sure it's
going on sorry to veer off a little bit
but I'm almost finished with the
purchasing process they let you put a
note in there okay so I said hi I'm
buying knives for people from Hannibal
Burres so that is
is that so I say something like you
should go by the handsome Rambler in
this case handsome Ram definitely from
the handsome Rambla from the handsome
Rambla crew I say you just give her like
a fortune cookie from the advice from
the crew of a handsome Rambler or like
and then some and then say like some
some weird
Confucius like advice a bird in the hand
kind of [ __ ] you bout to give a fortune
cookie
bow that's what if so would you give to
this to this girl yo the energy use
these knives to change your career thank
you for your help in ruining several
laptop keyboards just put if somebody
breaks in your house I hope they don't
find these nice okay man this don't
sound weird and maybe a holiday but is
that is that a thing is that like people
are watching porn and jizan so hard too
big just [ __ ] up computers is that I
have and I was just exaggerating but I'm
sure somebody that's right just just
came just came and just was like it just
was so grossed out by their own fluids
that they just tossed the computer is
this a bad that can't be it's too
expensive you can't have a $15.00 not
1,500 our nut bust you know there's
people out there day you know there's
people out there that don't that they
forget their computer and go out and
just buy another computer yeah I mean if
you have disposable money like that but
I'm saying you're not gonna first of all
you knowing you about to come and if you
standing over your keyboard that's of a
decision you make yeah but also I don't
think Jays ruins the keys for real right
let is sit there and it's a reminder if
it's a reminder of how your life is
going and you might ask you might toss
your computer but maybe yeah you have a
baby a smaller computer is born
[Laughter]
you come back the next computer the
computer just for that all right I'm
about the body's knives all right David
wait what's the message you left I said
I kept it simple I could change it I
said hey I'm buying knives for people
from the handsome man and now let's do
better
I need the to hand this maybe oh Jesus
suit like this all right okay I feel
like that needed fog action expect some
amazing [ __ ] out of you right I can't
pitch on this letter with my shirt on
you better be able to contribute to this
to this person oh the HP's about the key
the key
[Music]
yes hey what's up I was thinking about
you and figured you need some knives and
I bought you some alive I bought you
something up here and as I wish this I
hope you get this and then you use it to
cut up onions to cut up garlic so kind
of bell peppers to cut up all the stuff
you have in your closet this letter cut
holes into jeans cut collard greens cut
a proper in this please please please
please
[Music]
just napping on that organelle al I
think it was the shirt I think I'm
missing out and missing my Colantoni
the shirtlessness in the organelle
that's the new al right there Denver al
ladies and gentlemen Denver Jackson
that's your new name you are done you
reject outdoorsy do so no take your
shirt off then solitaire we should
mention it's a high school thing like
what in high squeeze always ask me I
think that's a grown man would you bet
would you bench you do what you bench it
what you throw it up we should thrown up
Deborah Jackson does yoga and runs along
trails he's like he's like the black Joe
Rogan dude I cannot get into outside man
I don't like it out there is I don't
like but I don't like it hot I don't
like I don't like bugs
I like air conditioning I like toilets
would I like unisex toilets they only
just got one in there you could shut the
door I like I'm not even fancy I just I
don't I like I just [ __ ] I just bought
the days for my bathroom at the crib
don't you do game changer bidets is the
most amazing what is a bidet cause under
$100 shut the [ __ ] up and you attach it
to your toy oh yeah yeah yeah yeah hook
up a little core and it's dope dude it's
I put them in I got them both my
bathroom so is your bday sit next to
your toilet like a sidecar on a
motorcycle or is it the same thing it's
no it's like a sock it's like a little
attachable thing it's just like a lever
that you don't owe your business and
then you move over six inches now dude
nope that's right yeah it's you it's in
there it's in the toilet it's in the
toilet that lever is on a side works and
it comes out and it still it's amazing
abused toilet paper but just basically
to dry off it's yeah even to wipe the
water yeah
and it's it's great you everyone
everyone
yeah the hallways the whole thing dude
if you if you if you picked up a piece
of [ __ ] right would you just put toilet
paper on it and consider your hands
clean you least want to water it off or
rinse it on ice like you're selling
bidets now III do it I'm pro bidet
everybody should have one especially
especially if you in a relationship and
things get boring and you might eat some
ass why would you not have a bidet yeah
go o4a the other day it's a bidet yo leo
yeah we go yo
well [ __ ] show to the front to the back
in the way quick back and shits with a
bidet in fact that go
who is the leader in bidet production
ooh who's the top of the day company I
don't know HP you got the computer right
there that's probably because I mean
it's just more fun to I would think it'd
be a European company yeah
but the Japanese have been on that
high-tech shift for a minute with the
bidets I would they make the 75% of
bathrooms and Japan has bidets just
built in them now it's a warm water
always top is it cold it's it's just
room temperature it's not like you're
not like you know it's like a it's like
a drinking fountain in the park it's
clean this filtered water comes from the
okay then it come from the toilet like
per say it comes from this hotel the
BEST bidet seat Toto watch lit offers a
heated seat and a water stream that you
can calibrate to your preferences better
than any other at this price the C 204
goes extraneous features you wouldn't
use anyway and it comes with a remote oh
why would you need why would you need a
remote for it that's unnecessary but
maybe you just like having that amount
of control when you're cleaning your
butthole but maybe maybe you're in a dom
sub relationship and your sub gives you
the remote and you go told us another
toilet you can control when she's done
and her water pressure there's that
there's also that sometimes hundred
twenty bucks too much that's not bad yep
because dude if you live in a place that
gets cold
that Toto also has a seat warmer because
they have that at my voiceover place in
LA and they have that exact same seat
and it's a seat warmer and I go and take
a [ __ ] just because I want to sit down
and I like having my ass cheeks toasty I
do like we like he that we like heated
floors don't work $400 a week do you not
like heated floors and a bathroom I
don't think right fancy man I'm just
saying we all like that [ __ ] but I'm
just talking about cleaning toilet seats
are disgusting it feels like someone
just took a [ __ ] yeah but you did just
take a [ __ ] somebody else yeah
[ __ ] he's talking about you sit down
when you sit down yeah I don't want to
be too comfortable when I take a [ __ ]
when I when I was in Mississippi hanging
with my cousin's it was shout out to the
sick yeah 601 the hit we went to their
football game then high school
homecoming game and I go to the bathroom
right before halftime and it's uh it's a
bunch of it's like bunch of teenagers
shooting dice in there and [ __ ] stop it
it's shooting dice and you know I liked
well I wanted to - again there and
there's a handsome gambler I took so I
took a piss and I farted while I piss
and then I guess the leader of the group
he but it's more like somebody farted in
here like yeah it's the bathroom just
gambling in the fart spot this is a room
buy-in for farts you're gambling in here
and it flies all around your dice game
that's why I didn't join cuz it was too
many flies by the game first of all I
just didn't know how many dudes far too
when they paid until I became a grown
man to started going to public bathroom
is fart before they pee and I don't it's
almost like starter you don't really do
don't know for it harder today but it's
as rare do you just don't fart you're
not a fart or not really know that was
that true you just killed a block I said
he broke your name and I apologize to
you for that I said my bad this is how
bad your fart was I was in the middle
Hannibal's up front and I was in the
back and he farted and he hit me and it
moving like Jesus do you ever fart and
then you wonder if you're healthy like
you think is nothing god that was gonna
come out having a healthy fire we were
walking no so that means they chased up
it wasn't like we were stationary we
were walking so I walked into it and
then it was like yeah now I'm about to
go get your boy right
it was it was very upset because I had a
very smug eight seconds well I got both
of with the [ __ ] heard that in like that
my farts are like white specialty
murmurs they work extra hard like my
first my first wanna make the 53-man
partisan yep
practice practice quiet linebacker you
got goddamn practice this punt team
gonna [ __ ] my farts we coming out with
small schools in the Midwest nosy V to
walk on fart got goddamn Central
Missouri six round draft a lot of it
bellezza themselves coaches talked as
part of an athletic ability makes up for
and spell and he's a great locker room I
remember watching him Rudy and being
like this guy just wasted his time he
wasted his [ __ ] time
was the promise of Rudy again what they
do that walked on the Notre Dame and got
in for like one played the end of his
career and it's like yeah if he didn't
get a movie made about him like that was
a huge waste of his time worked out got
it he got to be in shape for a few years
she got doesn't go to some parties and a
lot of t-shirts and gear and get went on
a writer in that movie no no I'm
thinking of a different one than you
think it a Girl Interrupted Winona Ryder
like his beetlejuice you know she was in
the movie Oh Lucas she was in that movie
and it again another thing a nerd trying
to do some [ __ ] for girl he
got lit up coming across the middle as
he should have because he shouldn't been
on the [ __ ] field if you're not built
to play football don't go out there
because you're trying to get some puss
some glands got lit up the one sack he
did have and stop trying to overachieve
to get some pudding Earl's will come
around it doesn't matter you have to
play football you dumb [ __ ] basically
basically I'll just says stay in your
lane has anybody would money have any
trouble getting girls that [ __ ] we're
real estate you ain't got a [ __ ] rut
stay in the slot yeah I don't know I
like the my the choices I've made in
life has led to me sitting at a table
with you in Iowa in the bathroom with
sunglasses wrong with people i sat on
the bench in high school for my first
three years and I feel like that [ __ ]
made me the person I am today cuz I got
bitter and I got sarcastic and like when
my coach would be giving like pregame
speeches he'd be like this they're not
gonna come into our house it pushed and
I'd be like playing the [ __ ] in
like two weeks
I remember sitting in my uniform doesn't
[ __ ] about this and I like I remember
like being a sophomore junior being like
oh life is way more important than being
a high school rather than some people
that like let high school affect them
for the rest of their life and be like
oh god I didn't make homecoming I knew
in high I was like this is a bullsh um
but I got it what position you play
shooting guard oh you see I thought you
suck at football you basketball shooting
yeah yeah how tall are you 6 feet
oh Jesus you guys yeah we're awful
aren't you
by the time I stopped my senior year
when I was getting playing time we were
horrible your [ __ ] because we just
six-foot shooting guard six-foot
shooting guard wasn't that fat every two
uh one time mom my coach's name was Pat
Moore coach Moore yeah and one time we
were running sprints and he stopped the
he stopped practice and he goes it I
thought this hilarious he stops and he
goes hold up hold up
timeout Jackson are you trying to dispel
the myth that all black men are fast
like we said that to my face I thought
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious you
can't say that [ __ ] no more because you
get fired but like this is the 90s and
like there was no cameras just said some
semi racist [ __ ] to me and we kept
playing you know why because back then
everyone have you all every coach had a
poster of Bobby Knight who is is a piece
of [ __ ] human being yeah Bobby Knight is
a piece of [ __ ] human being he's a great
coach there's no denying
you can be both people all understand
you can be both piece of [ __ ] human
being a great coach but they all thought
that the way to get the best out of you
is to belittle you right and we have to
believe on there was no in the 80s not
one coach was like hey man it's okay
right yeah like I got is cool so you
guys know how Asian parents do I think
especially I mean black parents to a
certain extent but I think brown people
that good that goes like Indian Asian
Hispanic definitely they are haters
towards their own people like if you're
not doing something mainstream like like
my boy Neel Nanda was on that vice show
the the flop house remember that that
kid that comic shop and he told me he
said he showed me the thing he sent his
mom with text Neil not his Indian Center
mom is
it's like you know I'm on national TV
tonight and she just text back sleeping
and it's just like do you don't obey job
they don't want creativity they don't
want it why I think they're just like I
thought I thought to get you to this
country get a job that we know it's
gonna make money engineering law
medicine and they don't they don't
understand until you're Aziz where
you're the most famous Indian person in
the Western Hemisphere like they don't
get it they're just like why don't you
just go get a job that you know is gonna
make money why are you even even so like
a lot of Asians don't make it in the
entertainment business and still be and
the parents will still be like you still
doing this [ __ ] I believe that no
it's weird let people like to put people
like parents make the mistake of liking
to put their dreams and aspirations on
you that's why you see those those like
it's like psychotic
American parents yelling at their kids
and sports and just breaking it out
because they want them to do what they
wanted to do and they couldn't and so
they put it on their kids and which is
and but yeah you can make the argument
that have the shows on TV whether it's
like Friday night tykes or even Dance
Moms it's just the people overweight
chicks that want their super in shape
talented daughters that yes like you're
here yelling at this girl that you you
brought your daughter to a building
where a [ __ ] fat egomaniac is
screaming at her and destroying her it's
like the fact that you do that shows me
that not only is this definitely not
about your daughter this is about you
because if anybody talked to yo cut kid
the way that dance my chick talks to
them girls or like any of them Friday
night tykes corner but that's the same
thing that's the same thing totally just
yeah going on with him except it's not I
mean truth be told if all parents are
monster so you want your kids to be a
monster to push your kids and a Madison
is [ __ ] and to be a [ __ ] dancer or a
soccer player some [ __ ] right yeah yeah
it's a weird they all they're all
they're all parents are the worst I I
deal with them morally and their I mean
my face they they've grown to accept and
they're cool now but in the beginning
how long did it yeah it's just about as
I love this [ __ ] off he's like what's
today check my text last Tuesday the
Chris Rock episode they don't even try
to explain them what the podcast was a
bomb I like oh you got a radio show
great
what channel I'm like that's not how it
works you have to seek it out doesn't
just pop off people can yo that uh that
des moms lady was on Eric Andre's show
watch before she went to the clink yeah
yep she was terrible
like at one point she cuz you know I'm
pigeon-toed and bowlegged and she
started saying some [ __ ] to me your mom
should have had you in Brighton leg
braces as a kid that was like a a black
song don't you ever get that thing where
you just go stop saying words that
you're saying so long word run hey shut
up shut up lady and then when we have to
be wrapped and she was in a grey room
and I was like yo you should shut the
[ __ ] up don't ever [ __ ] did he say
that yeah fine I snapped on her ass I
like don't have a bucket cause he was
like say whatever jokes you got for me
you know what I mean anything about me
cuz we you know we're being weird on the
show but I'm not
wouldn't that go on uh you know we're
not talking about family members and
[ __ ] she's like your mom's dumb as [ __ ]
yes lady and when I started seeing the
sequence core Nazi I was like yes you
should go to church she's in time to
review [ __ ] started subtweeting her like
do you think they'll have braces in jail
you said my mom's acquittal a great city
for leg braces on me you should have not
committed fraud how about that yeah they
caught her
they caught her like on an airplane
going off straight you were like 800
stacks in a briefcases alright trying to
launder that money I might do that [ __ ]
through the Cayman Islands you're going
to Australia for home
like fried or laundered money stealing
and [ __ ]
she got a year look man that's the only
thing where you can that will send a
white woman like in her fifties to jail
is when when you [ __ ] with the
government's money yeah anything else
like good they don't like they don't
like when listen we don't need you doing
that white women
right that's what stay in your lane we
will let you get away with a lot of [ __ ]
but don't you dare don't you dare do any
fraudulent money-laundering type [ __ ]
what else have you heard of a white
woman and her fifties going to jail I
mean that's insane like money [ __ ] well
if they killed somebody they'd probably
get them I mean that's that that's that
snap [ __ ] and then and even then they
like were you hurt were you abused yeah
please tell us that you were abused give
us a reason to let you go man to be to
be a white woman to just walk around
just knowing nothing that you do can get
you in jail you could get pulled over
you could talk [ __ ] and I heart the
store bounced right back
yeah she went to jail bounced right back
you were just YouTubed white girls
talking bad to cops this [ __ ] they say
is it a consolation [ __ ] incredible
just like yeah just like whatever [ __ ]
face dude I like saying that to the guy
like what I've saved this I've said this
once and I'm not taking it back at all
the worst hecklers I have in my show
when I do have them are white women they
are the worst they believe that they
have the right to talk during the show
not all white women I'm just saying the
ones they're heckle right the ones that
HECO are the worst hecklers are white
women it's not even it's not even close
and do you know where you get them first
of all I mean we we have footage of that
[ __ ] HP you remember Portland yeah it's
just in those small towns when it's like
the white girl that's like the hot girl
and like winston-salem or something you
know so she's never she goes to your
show and she's sitting there for like 20
30 minutes she's looking around
everybody's looking at you and she can't
she can't accept it
cuz everywhere she goes in that town
every time she goes to the Friday's that
she goes to the club she knows everybody
else ran Dee's
arts and we don't pay for anything like
they cannot understand that this
gigantic negro kevin Bozeman's in her
town and people are laughing at paying
attention to you so that's why that's
why you just you can just hear they're
not even heckling you sometimes are just
talking no yeah that's what I mean
they'll talk during this yeah my boss
wasn't at work today so now you're like
what you'd like Akane you're like what
are you I suck but just having a general
conversation a general Wingrove
it's it's really weird you know what
once my guy was driving us back from a
DJ gig and he was we were drinking
obviously they're in the gig he wasn't
like [ __ ] up but he was drinking and
we had this white girl in the back seat
and it was I guess his friend I don't
know from the burbs whatever and she
just I mean like he was playing it cool
the cop was cool we were gonna like you
know he was like you know you made a
legal left turn some small he was about
to let us go this girl just starts
barking like do you know who my dad is
and you are you and then right after
that friend catches the DUI because
she's because she she just had she had
to ruin the situation she had to say
something it's it's like yo just shut up
and let us handle this situation like yo
why are you barking right now like this
like you who was her dad I don't he
thought she was she was wealthy he was
wealthy that's it that's it
and I thought you don't know her dad was
the Comptroller like some some [ __ ]
doesn't that that money and said they
have money and they like all he owns
some kind of sums maybe scrap metal
company or some dumb [ __ ] I think a lot
of what that is Tony is I think that
they associate police as people to deal
with that their job is to deal with like
the lesser part of society yeah and the
fact that they're even being bothered by
how they cannot they're so offended
there's things they cannot believe
they're like shouldn't you be arresting
some Mexicans right now they cannot
believe what a cop has detained them you
see my immunity cloak yeah yeah if you
ever looked I remember um would eat this
is a year dear to before even
blacklivesmatter
there was a hashtag on Twitter called
cry meanwhile white and people were like
white people were starting to understand
like what white privilege was when
people are talking about like when black
people talking about like and when they
get pulled over by the cops and I read
this one tweet and this girl says I was
with my boyfriend he was hammered we got
pulled over the cop asks for his license
and the cop was looking at it she said
her boyfriend snatched his license back
out to the cops hand and told him to
[ __ ] off and drove away and the cop just
stood there and let him go and she was
and she was like that didn't hit her
that that was strange
yeah it was like that uh it was like
that whole OSHA pel bit from back
kilohms offing like it's so true close
your butt cheeks how about how about
dude yesterday in in Nebraska that's a
different situation but it's not the
police weren't involved but it was just
a different weird white situation we
went beat w3 no dude I I hated the fact
that Dave everyone we did wanted to take
pictures with you just would come up and
be like so you're clearly you're clearly
all former football players no yet so
that's explain that is explained was
yeah this explain what's happening
so yeah yesterday I was at we were at
bw3 Buffalo Wild Wings wait buffalo
wings buffalo wild wings three is was
there originally but we caught two bw3
oh good it's in Lincoln Nebraska which
is home of yes yeah and so we were
sitting just chillin watching the game
eating some wing you know a few people
came up and asked me for pitches and
then one guy after seeing this just
slaps the [ __ ] out of myself
yep from behind which is weird to do to
a stranger in these times and any times
but definitely and so and then he says
well you uh you take a picture with my
daughter's you must be a Cornhusker
player he just thought I was a full
yeah it was just like nah we not know
and I didn't give him any like Oh though
it's chilly just yo get the [ __ ] out of
here weirdo
you should have took that picture and
just signed it so I can Jeff Blake or
some old black quarterback no I don't
want to be a part of a bit that I can't
see all the way through no I'd rather
just shame him the fact that it's got to
be annoying know that okay fine if you
thinking I'm a football player but at
least you got it know which football
player you think I am you can't be like
yo you claim your former football player
so I know you come take a picture I
don't know who you are I don't know who
you are but I know that you used to be a
probably I don't know if you were third
string whatever I know you used to be a
football player come take a picture back
that goes to a theory that I've had not
you know I'd like to bounce this off
y'all see what your thoughts are on this
I feel like and this this has to do with
black people gay people Mexican people
it's considered a minority I feel like
if you're a regular white person that
lives in a country not a major city like
New York where you live in a building
with [ __ ]
I'm talking about like you live in the
Midwest or most of the country with
smoke I feel like you just you might not
know one single black person maybe
you're holding you might know like oh
there's there's Hannibal using my
eighth-grade English class but like you
you might not have a black friend you
might not have a gay friend they just I
feel like they just dog is racist right
they really just do I feel like a lot of
white people when would you ever run
into a black person except maybe like
coworker or something but like when
would you ever meet a black person I
think they're I think well it depends on
the city I think Lincoln I'm sure it's a
small black population but they have
some also I mean you know I've had
assumptions about people what I think
they do but I don't just run up on them
with my guesses I leave them to me and
my friends but because you're I think
cuz you're so exotic I think they'd like
to them there are black dudes sitting
2bw
how many black people weren't there when
we went in there it was us in a
bartender yeah that was [ __ ] up his
gag
he was [ __ ] up really yeah and I don't
know if you know it's gonna be kind of
joking with the bartender but he walked
away and she goes he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like in a non funny way yeah cuz she
made that joke like hey I hate first of
all she's talking us about him not
cleaning up her stations I guess what I
don't work here
right I don't want to hear about your
high politics she needed somebody to
vent to yeah but I just I honestly think
that a lot of people in the country
don't know a gay person or don't notice
that's why they like Oh gay people are
weird it's like when you know a bunch of
gay people when you're working in Tammy
you're like no they're not and so they
turn to Fox News to figure out exactly
they're like are the gays taking over
your high school it's like there's four
or five you know what else when I was in
college went to this guy's house with a
couple of my friends and they happen to
be black and this dog started going
apeshit on on them the two black guys
and we all just looked at this guy like
you don't have many black friends do you
know it's like sometimes when your dog
is racist yeah when you get on the
elevator and like a little white kid has
never seen a black dude before and yet
tell the Dare about to say something the
parent kind of grabbed because you could
see the get kid point about the asset
question they're like come here Timmy
are these the [ __ ] and you refer your
mom mom mom mom
Regan's I've told you I've told you that
story about when I was going to carpet
when I was going to st. Louis from
Carbondale we stopped at the gas station
little kid there was a little kid and
his mom and I heard like he tugged on
our pants it was like a look mom it's a
Chinese boy no yeah I was the first
Asian kid he ever seen well
congratulations
no kind of man yeah sitting next to me
with his shirt off and sunglasses so it
seemed I guess the far-fetched thing
next one with this shirt off and
sunglasses on did y'all get bullied at
all everybody got bullied alone even the
bullies get bullied that's why they
became bullies vicious cycle broken
glass everywhere
holy dad nobody cares hurt people hurt
people that's funny that's actually a
good point because you like you to stand
up yourself
don't let these bullies bully you like
yeah and you kick the bully's ass and
then you start kicking other people's
ass and you become a bully
I always felt that's work I always felt
the worst when some of my friends got
bullied and I wasn't like tough enough
to be like yo you ain't bullying my
friend no more
I used to be like damn this is [ __ ] up
and and I'm and I'm [ __ ] up the fact
that I did I won't do anything about it
like those are the things that bothered
me the most like when I look back right
like I'm talking 9 10 years old
like looking at my friends get bully and
then I'm just sitting back like damn
this is awful
yeah I saw I have guilt because I saw a
guy get bullied all four years of high
school he definitely had some kind of
growth issue you know like when I do
he's calm he's small obviously to be in
high school but like you can tell like
he's having some issues like where he
needs to take medication and so he was
unusually small to be in high school and
somebody that I know bullied him a lot
and I remember one day I'll never forget
you know me I don't remember a whole lot
man I remember one day he had brought
one you know that big pack of Twizzlers
that you get that like it's like at the
jumbo one and he brought it in all all
the black kids in my high school we sat
in like this one kind of corner area and
he brought it and was just trying to be
cool is like hey y'all I got Twitter's
for everybody you know I'm saying and
this dude took the bag and he just took
him because you know Twitter's are all
stuck together I was like a rope he took
him out and just he gripped he just
gripped all the Twizzlers he just ripped
them up just gripped him with it he was
a big dude and just like threw him down
and I just looked at that kid's face and
I was fried 6 15 16 but I was like the
first time I saw somebody that just
looked defeated like it was just like he
was just like I'm trying to this nice
thing and you could just ten people
laughed and it's just like I'll never
forget what his face looked like like he
was just so hurt he was just hurt
you don't say if you never you never put
that behind you do that that sticks with
you like yeah even if you go all and be
other things the life you might close
your eyes and imma [ __ ] still see his
twist list getting grabbed and gripped
and thrown and then it yeah for real
though and I and what and then that
whoever that do hopefully ends up he's
like I love wish people obviously you
shouldn't I loved wishing bad [ __ ] on
people it's like my favorite thing to do
yeah I love wishing bad [ __ ] on people
should get in the Wicca what is that
buttery like a Wiccan
[Music]
[Music]
chorus chorus death to you place cuz
everything has consequences left Paris
gentle voice
come on a devil who did see you first
once I do
dirty clothes
you yeah thanks PMS I could play that
every time I wish well people didn't now
let me ask y'all this do y'all believe
in anything it's not supernatural but do
you do you believe in energy do you
think they're like not that you can put
a curse on somebody but do you guys
believe in karma do you believe that
there is anything to voodoo do you
believe there's anything to pray and do
you believe that there's anything
outside of the physical like well
because well yeah touch yes yes
you always have always have lately
people get the wrong idea about karma
karma is actually a very very simple
notion it's not this mystical power its
energy that you surround yourself with
so if you are the type of [ __ ]
who likes to steal things and do bad
things to other people it attracts that
kind of energy to you so those kind of
people like to hang out with you and
then bad things happen to you and it
just keeps going and going it's
efficient but on the other hand if
you're a good person and you're like do
good things for people good people are
attracted to you and your circle of
friends and good people and good energy
grows that's what karma is it's not this
mystical power where it's like I stole a
candy bar I might something bad might
happen to me tomorrow I'm gonna do
something good and then karma will come
back my way if you have a good person
then karma puts good it's a path of
energy is what it is not a mystical
positive doing one random thing to try
exactly it's not it's not a deed for a
deed it's very simple you know you know
speaking of which I think I think Big
Mike might be locked out I should check
my phone ya know cuz the doors open I
can see it oh yeah yeah I'll pick my
right there
Big Mike did you grab this beer is it
here yeah Big Mike chilling on the ones
and twos
Big Mike did you grab with some beers oh
it opened yeah do we have any tequila or
whiskey
or vodka nah Mike's one another Amy lick
or at your pronunciation technique on
the yeah tequila vodka you look or you
say you saying that's it like you
teaches a body English keys la this is
how you do it when your dates I'm
drinking two shots of tequila I love it
keV where'd you play college ball again
I will Lakes two years so this is my
area where we ever play now oh yeah like
like I was north in here but I know this
whole like when we were coming in oh I
knew all of that weight position small
port oh [ __ ] all right man for anybody
that's des obviously can't see is Bose
is what I'm gonna guess 6 5 6 5 to 55
no sign up lost I'm to 35 to 35 30 to 35
yeah yeah yeah except maybe maybe not so
I would like two years and then two
years Wisconsin like wanna play
Wisconsin Whitewater shutout yeah yeah
ran that three spots son lockdown
defendant I ain't learnt how to shoot I
couldn't shoot until after I got done
the moment I stopped like leaves
basketball I couldn't miss did you play
all four years yeah [ __ ] - so - was that
a junior college junior college two
years Wisconsin Whitewater what was your
average as to junior college 13 and 10 I
was a I was a pop-up average 13 and 10
and then I went to whitewater just cuz I
want to be closer to home I actually had
a offer to go play and Regis College on
a river I had a offer to play and Dakota
State and it was getting to the
summertime and I didn't want to wait so
I was like you know what i'ma go ahead
and take this fee remission just what
they call it cuz you can give
scholarships and
three and I went to Wisconsin Whitewater
and I played three and I was just
strictly I play I got a point guards
through sinner's opposition all kind of
the original lamar odom i guard now dude
I was Tony Allen I was up in mugs dude I
was I was I was Aldi just defense that's
what's up yeah what was your move do you
like drop that baby hook nope my move
was somebody else shoot I got to offer
us a board yeah cuz like I'm six five
when my wingspan is six eight seven so
it's really long so I was all dude let
me put all right get the VCR put I'll
put a VCR on my wish list watch me I
have a question for a handful doom is
about Kevin do you think Kevin can still
dog no I say grace room I think yes sit
as well yeah I think I'll take him three
tries but he could do it regular
basketball tennis ball regular
basketball I'll throw down a tennis ball
I think three to five tries to do it
yeah I need I need to know days in
advance okay I need you to be able to
dunk
yeah so let's say a random millionaire
comes in he goes yo if you could dunk a
basketball in two Sundays we'll give you
two weeks of work out
Oh is he done oh no no okay I say it
Wednesday
you have to be able to dunk and I'll
give you 10,000 if you can do it but you
owe me 10,000 if you can't you get three
chances he taking it yeah I'm a gambler
why is it what do you think are you like
when you go in are you confident are you
like I think I can
oh Jesus I think I can you think you can
hands than one I don't know I kept ends
on how you jump some people - I'm a
vertical jumper so it was easy for me to
do with you and I thought oh hi like the
biggest o hands
don't let that dope don't get twisted
down anyway no kidding I can I can dunk
with two hands and that's how I did most
of my dogs
90% of all dunks in college it was to
him how many dunks did you have in game
the most I've had in the game was three
but I don't know how many I've had all
right so dope I let my in junior college
I led my squad in dunks and then my by
the time I got the Whitewater we had a
seven footer and a six they do so I had
to learn how to play the three what did
uh did you play against anybody that
ended up going pro and high school we
played against we were and I took I
think it took it and high school we were
we were ranked second in the state and
18th in the nation and then we play
lafawn zoe ellis who went to northern
day and was a lottery pick for the
Nuggets also played against Erik
Anderson who played the Indiana and
played for the notes yes Nikki for
Indiana and a Knicks and then just you
know playing in Chicago planning good
parks and stuff he always played again I
wasn't in the game when he played but we
played a Cleveland Central Catholic my
senior year in districts and Earl
Boykins was on a team he started Fred
saying he had 33 and 17 dollars in the
first half and didn't play this like
high oh [ __ ] yeah what's that what's
that is that the camera
the soundcheck
[Music]
was it closed up trying to catch it as
home gotta finish up so we talked for
out and sometimes that's time to move
over do some other things those it so
close up soul fit itself so that's how
both gotta fit us up self-serving with
Kevin Holmes
al Jackson old organelle versus sir
I can't tell down on the shades monetary
of all the tribes it might get a bad
wound
yeah
kappablues who's Baba right hey closing
up some catapodis a pop stand
I mean stand yeah let us all pray to God
did God thank you for everything thank
you for this food that we're about to
eat now right here they're people just
like that they thank God for everybody I
remember one time when I was a kid we
wish this couple was lost in a hood
trying to get to somebody's house and
this girl and our block tried to explain
it but she couldn't do a good job
explain it so they stopped let's like
hold on and then they started praying
asking for her so you have the ability
to give directions properly so they can
get to the spot Wow and then that like a
form of narcissism though that like you
think that God is like really interested
in you getting directions with all the
[ __ ] that's going on in the world it's
someone that had poor sheep wake was a
poor sheet over their eyes whatever
[Music]